today's topic Jenny slate from bigmouth
decides that she's no longer gonna play
a black animated character because black
animated character should be played by
black people this is what she said at
the start of the show I reason with
myself that it was permissible for me to
play Missy because her mom is Jewish and
white as am i but Missy's also black and
black characters on animated shows
should be played by black people
slate one ought to acknowledge that by
portraying Missy she was engaging in the
act of erasure of black people ending my
portrayal of Missy's one step in a
lifelong process and uncovering the
Rossi's of in my actions
big mouth co-creator Nick Kroll and
Andrew Goldberg Mark Levin and Jennifer
flack it posted a statement saying we
sincerely apologize for and regret our
original decision to cast a white actor
to voice a biracial character well I
mean first it's already stupid enough
because the character is biracial
so what only the black side of the
bi-racial person exists and that's the
only one that matters when they navigate
the world they're Jewish and the right
side which a black person may not be
able to identify with that's dumb
what's the point of acting literally
acting is about embodying the role of a
character what is the point only Muslims
can play Muslims only Christians can
play Christians men you like writing
stories involving women unacceptable you
can't write a woman how does that make
sense how do you know how many movies
you're going to have to eliminate
because men can't write women one of my
favorite voice actresses Regina King she
was the voice of Riley and Huey in the
boondocks can't do that no more yeah
because black women don't seem to live
the same experience as black men this
kind of logic if you take it down
towards its logical next step is bad
it's bad for society it's sure that fix
problems without fixing problems and I'm
not saying this okay dear reason for
corny dear white people like so I
understand you feel helpless and you
trying to fill you try to fix things
Sammy all summer y'all not all y'all of
course that's a given you're trying to
fix things
alright you're trying to do something
because you you see all these things
happening and it's so messed up times
that we have right now and you want to
do something and you sometimes asked our
and you wanna you really want to do
something but it's not gonna solve
anything
wanting to do something anything because
you want to have the feeling of doing
something to help the issue might not
help the issue by this logic if a white
person can't voice a black fictional
cartoon character you know what that
also means that means that a white
person can't write a black character so
you like the Marvel Cinematic Universe
no storm no Luke Cage it's part of this
bronze black goddamn star spawn was one
of my favorite characters too
the character is black and we see that
the character is black how is it eraser
because they feel like a black character
can really tell the story better oh we
see the character we see the key what I
see is black when I look at Cleopatra
okay done bad what was her name Liz
Taylor and she's white as black people
eraser okay cool but it was not white
okay so with historical figures you feel
a difference yeah that one thing okay
it's not the same thing
you know if you would have done Harriet
Tubman played by Jessica Biel what are
you doing
that would be erasure but now you're
you're you're drawing a character like
you're drawing a channel can fictional
character you drawing that character
character has a history it's black if
that character has a living experience
that is real but it's a fictional but
you see acknowledge that there's that
possibility I have mixed characters
mixed kids mix you know with both but
the voice is just we're gonna take that
out so okay you know what
only people that are black should draw
black characters yeah we should remove
the person that is white that drew that
character because only black people
should draw black characters no
but not all actions are better than
inaction your good intentions aren't
enough I know plenty people who are
well-intentioned who go about doing
things and what ends up happening is
that they hurt the very cause that
they're trying to help and this is akin
to that because by you taking this
action and thinking that you've done a
good thing when in potentiality you've
actually done a bad thing you may
actually hurt the very cause that you're
trying to do engage so I will tell you
to reflect take time to think about
these issues a little bit more in depth
and think am i doing something smart or
is this gonna be just viewed as virtual
signal now I don't know this person I
can't guarantee that their virtual
signal maybe they really reflected and
thought that this was the best course of
action but it doesn't change the fact
that it's a stupid choice to make some
of my favorite favorite movies were
written by white people about black
people some of my favorite characters
were written by white people I don't
think that their whiteness means that
they cannot sympathize and try to
understand a situation is it gonna look
different than if a black person who
actually can empathize who's lived the
experience writes the characters gonna
be potentially probably but it doesn't
mean that both can't do them justice I
didn't identify well with Jordan peels
movie is he a black creator yeah
should you have a chance to make those
movies oh great but for me personally
there are identified more with Fresh
Prince of bel-air who is the writer for
precipice suzanne and andy Borowitz
created The Fresh Prince almost 30 years
ago so Jewish people but it was also
backed by a clip see my whole point
being is that white people can be
involved in the creation of black
stories and still be able to tell them
justly it doesn't mean that black krater
shouldn't be also involved or if they
should be able to create their own
stories the whole point being is that
it's not because you're from a different
background that you can't tell a story
you're wrong
andy Borowitz made some black people
erasure by creating bel-air you see how
dumb is that you know you see how do you
know how difficult my or different my
childhood would have looked if I didn't
have the French prison for me growing up
in Ethiopia where that was my only form
of black television it was super
impactful from listen you let you live
Ethiopia was your only black form of
television I live in Canada and that was
my only lack you know that far off there
brother right and so I would just let I
would just tell you guys this is a
dangerous road to going down very
dangerous and I think we're starting to
see we're not started it's been going on
for quite some time but it's going down
a bad place oh one minute sorry this is
going down a bad rabbit hole this is
going down a bad who are losing their
mind the amount of identity politics are
being involved it's not like voice
acting has some kind of scenario where
black voice actors can't get work there
are so many great black voice actors
thriving and killing it at the highest
of levels the highest of levels so to me
this is just so stupid it's just stop
you're not doing something good and the
last line I would say is this you had
great intentions great but recognize
that the road to hell is paved with good
intentions you can take people down some
terrible places because you are well
intentioned but if you don't know where
you're going no matter how well
intentioned you are you may still be
leading people to a bad place
if you don't know where you're going and
you're still taking action you're still
lost but if you don't think the right
path you're still gonna be lost yeah
doesn't matter you know what we when I
was in the military and we would have to
do topography or in the woods you did
though we'd have to look at
constellations and stars and event
understand or north or south they would
tell us don't move around endlessly take
a time to get your bearings understand
that where you're trying to go look to
the Stars for guidance so that they can
lead you in the right place understand
your north/south use terrain use
monuments if they're around use whatever
you can to be able to guide you properly
what I feel like is we have a whole
bunch of people who are trying to move
right now and have never studied Maps
and it's dangerous because you may be
leading people to the enemy you may be
leading people to a cliff we don't know
if it's over there it's a ravine
you're all dead yes that's what if he of
yes topography was a really interesting
class it was never skill that I thought
I wanted to learn but my sense of
direction now is amazing and I'll be
like yo North is that way that's where
we should go do you like what's way
north don't have mine you don't know
that streets go east to west north like
hugged and you're like I got my GPS well
what are you doing your battery's dead
they're just like right now I don't want
to die I know you're bad solutions and
get your together and some of y'all are
acting like you don't have a GPS right
now and your batteries are dead that's
right and bigmouth is a great show don't
quit it though and I know that we're
going through changes use your head use
your big-ass mouth going through changes
that's it for today's video leave a
comment leave a like we want to hear
your thoughts what do you think about
all this
[Music]
[Applause]
my favorite voice actor is the guy who
plays Kratos in God of War white
character white Greek guard Spartan okay
but he had to have that bass in his
voice who was the actor one of the most
chocolaty is men he's not he's not he's
not dark but whatever take Bobby
Caldwell great great great singer again
loved it loved funk music my favorite
what you won't do do for love right
great song everything let sit down love
right great song right black people we
got funk man stepped out of the shadows
like a hidden character he's like I'm
white right the reason why he had to
hide his identity because a lot of
people felt like a white person can
never do funk that well so his label
purposefully try to hide as I didn't
alot of ways and why am i bringing this
up because I feel like now we're doing
the same thing here we're telling people
that they shouldn't and that it kind of
contributes no I feel like all that
matters that you do justice to the
characters these are fictional
characters that are trying to tell a
story